i William Arthur Quinton returning
officer for the Ipswich constituency
declare that the total number of votes
given to each candidate was as follows
hacking whale Chica Liberal Democrats
1400 Broome Barry Green Party 1736
Ellesmere David Thomas Labour Party
18,000 and 61 gamma then Conservative
Party 21,000
794
794 venu maria UK Independence Party
5703 therefore I give public notice that
Ben gamma is duly elected as the Member
of Parliament for the Ipswich
constituency the total number of votes
cast across the Ipswich constituency at
the UK parliamentary election on the 7th
of May 2015 was 48,000 833 the total
number of ballot papers rejected was 139
the ballot papers were rejected for the
following reasons
there was one ballot paper was it was
rejected because they did not bear the
official mark 30 ballot papers were
rejected because votes were given for
more than one candidate 3 ballot papers
were rejected because there was
something written or marked on the
ballot paper by which the voter could be
identified 105 ballot papers were
rejected because they were unmarked or
void for uncertainty I will now give
each candidate the opportunity to say a
few words
Thank You mr. mayor I am humbled to be
asked to serve for another five years as
the member of pomp this great time
the only pride that I take from this
significant electoral achievement is the
pride in my magnificent campaign team
and especially Olivia Willett my
campaign manager my president Paul West
the chairman of the Association
Elizabeth hasent and the deputy chairman
political who over the past five years
have helped craft this campaign Steve
and I on Kim strode Bob Hall and
Katherine Parkinson and I'd also like to
thank you mr. mayor for being a
typically elegant a returning officer
and also to the acting returning officer
and two the count staff and the polling
agents and to the police and I would
like also and perhaps most of all to
thank my family Sarah and my brother and
two sisters I would like to thank the
opponents in what has been a vigorous
but decent fine and especially David and
I should say that this has been
difficult campaign I know for the Labour
Party in many ways stalked as it has
been with some considerable sadness the
people of Ipswich have asked me to serve
them for another five years they have
asked me to fulfill a vision that I made
very clear to them over the course of
this campaign they've asked me to bring
better railways to the town they've
asked me to bring better roads wet
crossing in a northern route they've
asked me to help Forge and restore a
better town center they've asked me to
start the work on new buildings at
Ipswich Hospital but they have asked me
to bring full employment to our town for
the first time in many decades
and new homes to house families and
they've asked me perhaps most
importantly to ensure that schools in
our town which are in no way fit yet for
the people of Ipswich are good or
outstanding by the end of that five year
term that in itself is a mandate to
local government in Ipswich and in
Suffolk to put aside their differences
and to make sure that we realise this
ambitious vision for this great town of
ours which has so much potential but it
is also a mandate for a Conservative
government a government believes in
sound money a government that believes
in investment in infrastructure and in
the NHS and a government that continues
to drive for excellence in schools and
it is that last which is particularly
important to me because over the next
five years if we do not fulfill that
noble mission to make sure that everyone
in this country from no matter where
they come and to wherever they wish to
go can fulfill their full potential
potential is the watchword of this
national campaign and also this campaign
here in Ipswich the potential of this
great town and every one of its citizens
and the potential of this great nation
and every one of its subjects is far
greater that we have become accustomed
to accept ifs which people know this the
British people know this this election
is a mandate to us to deliver that
vision thank you very much
you